okay he is Professor of marketing at NYU
Stern School of Vis is a host of the
prop gpod with Scott Galloway Scott
Galloway is back with us how are
you okay she's a co-host of the Five on
Fox News and head of resarch at Buell
Jessica tarlo Jessica how you doing
finally got you here
yes okay so I want to start off with
this Mike Johnson I know everyone is
saying Mike Johnson my insurance
agent
no the other Mike Johnson he's the
speaker of the house now so I've been
using this very slow moving coup about
Trump since before he got elected the
first time and a lot of people were
laughing I see a lot of people use it
now uh and every time we don't
completely lose our way of government
somebody says oh well where's your slow
moving coup now it's slow that's my
answer it's slow but this what happened
this week I I remember I did a very dark
editorial like 2022 like the last one of
the year after that election saying
because we all thought the Republicans
going to win and I said what's going to
happen is that the people who were not
in place in 20120 that Trump tried to
get his bidding to overturn elections
the John rafen Bergers of the world who
said no I can't find you
votes they're all going to get replaced
and it didn't happen then but that's
kind of happening now with Mike Johnson
the ultimate election denier and now all
the Republicans it took him 22 days to
get this guy
but now they finally got the guy who's
Trump's guy you know it takes time to
get your people to infiltrate them into
these positions but I'm sorry I think
that thesis still holds and I think is
this the moment let me ask you the
question the Republican party is just
the Maga party now right
this I think so I I felt that way for a
while and there were a few kind of
glimmers and I think Kevin McCarthy was
like this fancy shiny object that a lot
of people thought never heard him
describe that way but well he's handsome
he's Charming he's the number one
Republican fundraiser out there right
even in the last quarter he raised $4
million he's the he's the Nancy Pelosi
of the other side in terms of raising
money wow I I I I don't this is a side
of him I never thought of well that's
what I'm here to deliver I see
um no I just having spend a lot of time
in the conservative ecosystem these are
things that I pay attention to why is
this one more useful than this one for
instance and Kevin McCarthy comes off as
someone normal he is not normal right
he's someone who had a day where he said
you know Donald Trump is responsible for
January 6 and the next day he was at Mar
Lago throwing back martinis and hanging
out with the crew
so but this guy also has a Sheen to him
right he doesn't present like what you
would think you last week we thought it
was going to be Jim Jordan right has no
proper clothes you know sits like this
whatever and then we get this guy who's
a lawyer who has a long career of going
after these kind of social issues you
already mentioned it in the monologue
about the sodomy laws criminalizing
homosexuality he was in the election
Integrity front he wasn't just someone
who signed on he was an architect of the
plan to get our votes thrown out in
Pennsylvania and Georgia and Michigan um
he is so much more frightening in that
sense but I do think and obviously want
to hear what you guys think about this
as well I think it is a good thing for
Democrats that he was made speaker
because everything is laid bare now if
you listen to his interviews you know
exactly who this party is and Democrats
can run against that it's harder to run
against Kevin McCarthy who might feel
more normal to you do we
keep do we keep hoping oh this time
it'll show them for who they are I this
is just enormously disappointing we are
we are normalizing climate change we are
normalizing anti-Semitism and we are
normalizing a kicking out of the legs of
the stool of democracy Central to our
democracy regardless of what you think
about our country it's the best of its
kind so far hands down democracy the
pillars of that are one the peaceful
transfer of power and this guy was an
architect of trying to arrest that and a
society that is secular and when a guy
gets this nod and says that God ordained
it I'm like well boss whose God is that
because this is the whole point here is
that we separate church and state that
we believe in the peaceful transfer of
power and the reason this guy is speaker
is none of us had the time to read his
resume and realize he's David Duke light
well we did
now well I don't I don't know if he's
David Duke light I read today he has an
adopted black son yeah I don't think
David Duke would do that but he is but
he is a religious nut I he was the
lawyer for Alliance defending Freedom
this is from their literature they seek
to recover the robust Christian doic I
don't know that word you're a professor
maybe you do Christian Christian doic
Theology of the third fourth and fifth
centuries you know maybe the
fifth a little more
reason but the third and
fourth I mean that he he uses the phrase
the socalled separ ation of church and
state this see this is the alliance of
this is I hate the you know fascism the
word is throw around but it's always the
farri church folks meet with the
corporate power folks that's muscolini
that's that's all these fascist States
and this is now that and of course Trump
doesn't give a either way about
religion he'll say Whoever likes him
right he will sure I'm down with so he's
of course going to just cave on all this
religious non ense from the fifth
century we're going back to now so um
look the biggest threat I think to
civilization right now isn't a murderous
autocrat Putin that's a threat or
jihadist that's a threat the biggest
threat I believe is political extremism
in the greatest force in the world and
that is on the far left we have
apologists for terrorism and on the far
right we now have a speaker who is
claiming that school shootings shootings
are a function of them teaching
evolution we are literally being torn
apart internally and we no longer going
to have the fabric and the muscle to
occupy the position we command and that
is the greatest force in the history of
the world this is our problem we're
rotting from the inside out when you're
this much of a religious fanatic there
is no room for real
democracy